[Music]
it's a moment they've waited five years
sealing their relationship their way
against all odds we succeeded in a legal
battle against the government and then
they did what we asked but all alone not
many people can say that the legal
battle Rebecca and Charles started to
get here made it all the way to the
Supreme Court today the ending they
fought for a short private ceremony and
the right to a civil partnership we're
able to kind of mark this moment and be
a partnership of equals and set an
example for how we want to bring up our
children and to have done it together
it's really great to actually sit down
and rather than writings at a political
campaign speech to actually write down
you know this is why I love you these
are all the things that I think are
wonderful about you it's taken a long
court battle to get here but this was
about making the rules the same for
everyone
Rebecca and Charles wanted to legally
bind their relationship without what
they saw as a patriarchal associations
that come with marriage civil
partnerships have long been allowed for
same-sex couples and many thought they'd
be phased out altogether when gay
marriage became legal but increasingly
heterosexual couples wanted and fought
for the rights and protections a civil
partnership offers without a wedding
marriage has patriarchal baggage it's
true also that you know opposite sex
relationships are unequal in in many
ways not because of marriage but just
because of the society that we live in
so perhaps civil partnerships will be a
catalyst for change other couples have
celebrated being among the first
heterosexual civil partnerships it's
estimated eighty four thousand more will
join them in 2020 it's been a long road
to get rid from the Supreme Court tip
Chelsea town hall where five years ago
Rebecca and Charles were refused a civil
partnership today they walked out not
bride-and-groom but something altogether
more important to them an excuse kind